This is the AMD RX460
RG Stricks Edition. Featuring a two fan
custom design, RGB customization, and
higher clock speeds, this could well be
the card for everyone. But is it
actually any good? Well, I found out.
[Applause]
[Music]
And so then the Radeon RX460,
AMD's answer to those that just want to
play PC titles and aren't really that
fussed about playing them at high
resolutions and high settings. This
budge orientated card from Asus features
4 GB of VRAM, a two fan custom design,
and it comes very well presented. It's
not a very big card, especially when you
compare it to a full fat RG strict card
from the likes of the 1070 and the 1080.
It is a very small card and you
shouldn't really have too much trouble
fitting it in your case whatsoever.
Taking a closer look at the card reveals
that ASUS has gone for an open air
design and it features a jet black color
scheme with an RGB logo located on the
top. This means that it should fit
nicely in with any motherboard and any
case. Look to the eye of the card and
you'll find one display port, one DVI,
and one HDMI 2.0. While we do expect to
see compromises at this price point, it
is a shame that we don't have two
display ports. As if you do want to run
two Freync monitors or just two display
port monitors of this card, you'll be
unable to do so. Move to the back of the
card and you'll see that a custom back
plate is sadly missing. But of a card of
this size and at this price point, this
isn't really a big deal at all. But it
is very nice that ASUS have included a
fan header on the GPU that you can plug
a fan into and then have a custom fan
curve that's related to your GPU
temperature rather than just your
motherboard temperatures or your CPU
temperature. Move around to the top of
the card and you'll find the ROG Stricks
logo, an illuminated RGB ROG logo, and
then the power connector, which is a
single six pin power connector, which
should allow you to do some tweaking if
you want to, but it's not really going
to be the sort of card that you're going
to get that much additional horsepower
out of. Getting the card in your case is
very simple because of its small size
and the RGB customizable logo does make
this thing a little bit more attractive,
but overall it isn't the most
fascinating card out there. So maybe
it's time to talk about gaming
performance. And to kick us off, let's
start with the Valley Extreme HD
artificial benchmark. And here you can
see the RX 460 is less than half the
speed of the RX480,
which is immediately a little bit
worrying because this card is about £60
cheaper, maybe slightly more, slightly
less depending on the price. But the RX
480 is over double the performance. So
if you work this out from a price
performance perspective, you can
actually see that the RX 480 is much
better when it comes to price
performance than the RX 460 is. But
before we draw our conclusions, we
probably should look at some other
titles. And as a gaming card, the RX 460
does do what it sets out to do. Bearing
in mind that all of these presets are
more or less on the ultra preset. You
can still get a fair amount of frame
rate with both 1440p and 1080p settings.
And of course, you can tone the settings
down to tailor your experience to the
game and the frame rate that you're
after. But having said that, when the
results are this different between the
RX 460 and the RX 480, it does really
make you wonder whether you should
actually just save up a little bit
longer and buy the RX480.
Unfortunately, I don't have the results
of the RX 470 here, but they will be
within the middle of these two results.
Looking closer at the Far Cry Primal 4K
result definitely proves that this is
not a 4K gaming card whatsoever. If you
do want to do some video editing and use
this as a rendering card, then in that
respect, it's probably not a bad shout.
But once again, because of its lack of
two display ports, it's going to limit
you if you are a creative professional.
But if you are considering this card,
then there are no doubt two questions
you're asking yourself. The first one
is, can it actually run the games I want
it to run? And if you are after a 1080p
monitor, you want to play games in 1080p
and you don't mind turning a few
settings down or you're playing less
intensive titles, then this thing is no
doubt going to be able to cope very
well. And you may well ask, why do I
need more performance to which then
yeah, absolutely this card is probably a
solid bet. But for those that are
willing to spend a little bit extra,
you're going to be getting much better
value for money and it comes with more
ports. And just generally speaking, it's
a much better card and it offers much
better value for money and it will last
you a lot longer. But I think the people
that are looking at the RX 460 are those
that just want to play PC games. To
which I can say that this will do a
solid job at 1080p. But I don't feel
comfortable giving this an award. mainly
because it's just not the best option
out there, especially the stricks
edition which adds extra cost onto an
already fairly expensive card for what
it is. And if you do go for a cheaper
variant with only 2 gig of VRAM, then
you will be limited with things like
textures and just it's not really the
most appetizing card in my personal
opinion. But there we go. That has been
the review of the RX 460. I hope you've
enjoyed it. Let me know what you
thought. If you enjoyed it, please leave
a comment down below. Hit the subscribe
button if you want to see more videos
like this. There are plenty other
graphics card reviews to help you choose
your next GPU beast. And a massive thank
you to you guys for watching. A massive
thank you to ASUS for providing this
review sample is appreciated. As always,
let me know what you thought. Hit the
like button if you liked it, dislike if
you didn't, and I'll see you in the next
video. And thanks to Corsair as always
for sponsoring the channel.